[Music]
the wait
is finally over on thursday cardi b
and megan d stallion dropped the video
for their new single [ __ ]
and not only is it the dream collab
we've been waiting for
the video is jam packed with surprise
celeb cameos
including drum roll please kylie jenner
i love it yup that's the beauty mogul
walking in super slow-mo down a long
hallway straight up slaying in leopard
print
thigh-high boots a matching bodysuit
with strategic cutouts that found her
signature curves
gloves and a cape naturally
i'm excited about it the reality star
even shared a behind the scenes pick on
instagram but she isn't the only star
who makes an appearance
yep that's normani behind door number
one
and that that's rosalia looking fire in
head to toe
red latex
and it doesn't stop there cardi and meg
peep behind a few
other doors and spot mulatto sukihana
and ruby rose too i'm like these are the
girls that
i personally like that i like their
music that i really feel
like they are going to go mainstream
like to me cardi dished about the
star-studded music video on new music
daily on
apple music friday i wanted like a lot
of different females not just
female rappers and y'all gonna see it on
the the music video as well from models
to influencers and everything and i and
i really wanted like the video to be
very sexy very clean very nice very cut
cardi she's all about that women
supporting women vibe
it feels really amazing you know a lot
of people be thinking like
it's supposed to be like a catty thing
and it just feels good like when other
women show love to each other and they
don't know how much
like that means to me though like that
that means that yo
you know what one day you need a kidney
i might give you minds
and i barely drink so they might be
mines might be good
shortly after the video dropped the
rapper hit up her insta story to thank
all the fierce females who pitched in on
wap
i want to thank all the girls in our
music video um
mulatto sukiyana ruby rose normani
kylie jenner rosalia thank you so much
and she even belted out a few lines from
normani's motivation
[Music]
and on thursday a few hours before the
rappers blessed us with the collab to
end
all collabs cardi teased what fans could
and shouldn't expect on instagram
i just want to let y'all know i want to
give you a heads up with the music video
is going to be the sensor version of the
song because the song is so nasty that
youtube was like hold on wait a minute
song just might be too goddamn nasty so
the
song with the music video is censored so
make sure you get the real
sh on all streaming platforms
and on that note let's sign off with a
little help from cardi
and
[Music]
and
megane